el chip cambiado con ganas de mejorar y
de alcanzar todos nuestros sueños y
nuestras metas
bueno
creo que en la mañana lo primero que
nosotros hacemos es agarrar y mirarnos
al espejo pero
que realmente lo que nosotros vemos
cuando nos miramos al espejo
nosotros vemos un cuerpo físico
pero más allá de eso
qué es lo que realmente hay qué es lo
que realmente nos mueve qué es lo que
realmente nos motiva
y es que la vida se pasa pero volando y
claro como todas las imágenes están
dadas en este mundo que está cada vez
más deprisa
nosotros lo primero que hacemos es decir
que estoy haciendo
eso fue lo que me pasó a mí entonces yo
decidí poner cuatro puntos con los
cuales yo empecé a descubrir mi
conciencia
porque eso es lo que realmente nosotros
en algún momento de nuestra vida tenemos
que hacer porque
porque vivimos la vida generalmente en
piloto automático
corremos corremos que tenemos que salir
profesionales que tenemos que tener un
trabajo estable que tenemos que seguir
el negocio de la familia en fin todas
las imágenes nos están dadas y nos están
diciendo todo el tiempo la sociedad qué
es lo que tenemos que hacer
y
y es complicado para uno agarrar y
pararse y decir
qué es lo que realmente pasa
en historia de vida también pasó algo
similar
por qué
yo también corrí mucho corrí demasiado
yo a mis 25 años
tenía una profesión tenía maestría
tenía un trabajo estable
trabajaba en la empresa familiar
y al parecer todo estaba bien porque
esas imágenes fueron las que me fueron
dadas
para alcanzar el éxito
pero de pronto un día cuatro de la tarde
todo cambio porque me levanté en mi
escritorio y me sentí pésimo
sinceramente sentí que me iba a morir
mareos
y claro me asusto y le digo a mi hermano
y le digo vámonos a la clínica me estoy
muriendo entonces claro nos vamos al
hospital más cercano
y después de más o menos tres horas de
análisis y todo
me diagnostican que tengo estrés
y odio qué cosa más rara si he hecho
todo lo que tenía que hacer
para tener una vida exitosa
y estoy estresado
realmente fue algo que me hizo clic
entonces
se viendo esta frase de camión que dice
que hasta que el inconsciente no sea
consciente el subconsciente dirigirá tu
vida y tú le llamarás destino
claro tenemos nosotros tres tipos de
mente la mente consciente que es la
mente racional que es todo lo que
realmente vemos vivimos tenemos una
mente subconsciente que la que está un
poquito más atrás de la mente consciente
que es la que podemos recordar con
alguna facilidad les doy un ejemplo si
nosotros
tomamos por ejemplo un basurero y
tenemos este basurero estamos y tiramos
la basura todos los días ahí y los
movernos del lugar
seguramente dos o tres días en el lugar
anterior a buscar en el basurero esa es
nuestra mente subconsciente porque
necesita estamos programados para
hacerlo y cuesta de programarse
entonces la mente ya inconsciente es
donde se quedan claves más atrás de la
subconsciente donde realmente se
encuentran todos los eventos que nos han
pasado en nuestra vida
qué pasa
para hacerlo un ejemplo gráfico
nosotros tenemos por ejemplo un niño un
niño que le encanta jugar fútbol le
encanta jugar fútbol y dice
y de pronto alguien lo ve medio patear
mal el balón y le dice no son buenos
para jugar fútbol
entonces claro el niño hace consciente
de que no es bueno para jugar fútbol y
cuando quiera volver a jugar fútbol su
subconsciente le va a decir que es malo
para jugar fútbol
entonces
lo que dice yum es que nosotros tenemos
que volver lo inconsciente consciente y
lo que tiene que hacer ese niño es tomar
el balón y vencer a su subconsciente y
realmente tomar las riendas de su vida
y bueno
yo agarré vivo después de todo lo que lo
que a mí me pasó
yo realmente era feliz
por qué
complicado
agarrar y después de que todo
todas estas experiencias que yo tuve
no soy feliz
entonces
ahí se el segundo clic
después de la frase de yum
y señores lo que yo les quiero decir que
la felicidad en realidad es igual a la
realidad menos la expectativa que uno
tiene
esa expectativa para hacerlo más
sencillo
es lo que siempre nosotros decimos yo
voy a ser feliz cuando
yo voy a ser feliz si esto pasa
y hacemos de la felicidad
solamente momentos
y eso fue lo segundo que me pasó a mí
claro yo dije yo voy a ser feliz cuando
ingresé a la empresa familiar
y sí sí que ese momento fui súper feliz
después de tanto estudio de tanta
preparación me siento en mí en el sillón
de mi escritorio y
y me sentí feliz
porque mi realidad que estaba haciendo
igual a mi expectativa
pero lamentablemente
la felicidad va más allá de ser un
sentimiento
la felicidad para que realmente sea
duradera
tiene que tener un propósito
si no no está completa te voy a dar un
ejemplo de la felicidad cómo funciona
con nuestra fórmula
nuestros padres en realidad nuestros
abuelos cuando cuando les dijeron a
nuestros padres
tenéis que trabajar tenéis que hacer
esto tienes que hacer lo otro
y lo realmente
y le pusieron expectativas pequeñas
a nuestros padres porque el mundo era
duro
pero después
no se dieron cuenta en los años 80-90
con los vuelven económicos que realmente
como se expectativa era pequeña y su
realidad fue mucho mayor a su
expectativa ellos de alguna manera
estuvieron mucho más felices que por
ejemplo la generación de ahora la
generación de ahora mucho más
competitiva y con muchísimas
expectativas
y al final de cuentas claro crecemos con
unas expectativas gigantes y la realidad
nos da una bofetada
y ahí es cuando realmente aparece el
tercer punto
qué es la felicidad realmente consciente
es duradera y para que sea duradera
tiene que tener un propósito
y el propósito tiene que ser conjugar lo
que uno tiene que hacer en la vida con
lo que ama hacer con lo que uno vino a
hacer pero que eso por ejemplo lo que
uno tiene que hacer no es necesariamente
lo que uno ama hacer como por ejemplo
hacer las cosas cosas cotidianas de la
casa
tener un trabajo una familia etcétera
conjugarlo con uno con uno realmente ama
a ser lo que uno ama ser es su propósito
es realmente lo que uno lo que uno viene
a hacer y lo que disfruta tu pasión y lo
que viniste a ser es muy parecido a lo
que amas a hacer nada más que no se
trata solamente de uno sino también de
dárselo a los demás
después de este tercer clic
deje de estar en piloto automático
y realmente
tomé el volante y tome las riendas de mi
vida
y dije
quiero ser emprendedor
y fue muy difícil decirlo
y fue más difícil aún
acercarme al
a mi familia mis hermanos a mis tíos
padres etcétera
y decirles que yo no iba más en la
empresa
pero realmente eso era lo que tenía que
hacer porque uno tiene que ir y buscar
su propósito
por eso
viene el cuarto clica ok ahora quiero
ser emprendedor
pero para emprender se necesita muchas
agallas
se necesita mucha pasión y por eso
es que
hice esta última fórmula
que para alcanzar tu propósito necesita
determinación menos miedo la
determinación
es lo que realmente te tiene que mover
es lo que realmente me movió a mí en el
momento de decir a mis padres a mis
hermanos
esto no va más
y obviamente uno tiene miedo
porque realmente uno que ha al azar
porque de alguna manera cuando uno está
bajo la bajo el yugo familiar tiene algo
de seguridad
pero hay que sobre sobreponerse al miedo
entonces
allí
fueron los cuatro puntos donde yo hice
clic
y luego volvía al espejo
y ahora miro
miro el mismo cuerpo físico pero digo
quien vive sin un propósito no encuentra
su rumbo y quien vive de una manera
consciente despierta muchas gracias
[Aplausos]